au lac et colas et à nos bactéries qu'on
peut observer c'est surtout au niveau ça
s'accumule surtout au niveau de la rive
les cyanobactéries ou algues bleu-vert
n'ont pas encore été détectée ici cette
année
mais dans ce lac de saint-hippolyte dans
les laurentides le problème est connu on
avait déjà fait faire une étude en 2001
on avait refait faire l'exercice en 2007
puis le bail d'un an plus tard 2018 ont
fait affaire l'étude troll de
l'étouffante enola un chercheur embauché
par la municipalité a observé une
prolifération de cyanobactéries au lac
écho pourtant le ministère de
l'environnement ne fait plus d'analystes
dans ce plan d'eau il ne s'attarde plus
qu'à ceux qui sont une source d'eau
potable
résultat en dix ans le nombre de lacs
officiellement touché par une floraison
d'algues bleu vert est passé de 167 à 4
seulement le problème a pas disparu il
ya vraiment changé en fait au contraire
le problème s'accentue et partout dans
le monde on voit une augmentation de
fleurs de cyanobactéries en lien avec le
grand air l'augmentation de
l'utilisation des lacs mais aussi à
cause des changements climatiques alors
les températures plus élevées peuvent
aider la croissance ici nos bactéries
les algues peuvent provoquer de
l'irritation des maux de ventre ou
encore de la diarrhée
arrêtez les analyses c'est comme se
donner un faux sentiment de sécurité
selon cet expert faut avoir un suivi
puis il faut bien informer les gens
faucon et leur jeu c'est faux que les
citoyens qui ont un problème grave dans
nos lacs sachets ce que est ce que c'est
vraiment un risque que ce n'est pas
vraiment un risque pourquoi pourquoi
laisser ça à ces gens-là de deviner si
prennent la chance ou potes se baigner
ou prendre la chance ou pas de faire du
kayak mais saint-hippolyte n'a jamais
vraiment compté sur le ministère de
l'environnement
depuis longtemps elle a mis en place des
mesures pour protéger ses lacs laisser
nos bactéries les comptes en finale pour
qu'elle se développe c'est d'avoir
il a peut-être d'ensoleillement une
certaine température de l'eau mais aussi
ça leur prend du coffre du phosphore il
y en a dans les matières fécales donc
ici depuis 2006 près de 20% des fosses
sceptiques ont été remplacés mais du
phosphore il y en a aussi dans les
engrais utilisés en agriculture dont il
faut limiter les rejets dans les cours
d'eau ce sont quelques unes des
solutions pour combattre les algues
bleu-vert ici sébastien desrosiers radio
canada saint-hippolyte